obviously yeah because it's hard
negotiation process does not end here
after the approval of this last package
according to the deal of 12 july package
of prior actions we are obliged to
negotiate again with the st. persistence
and passion in order to agree on the
terms of the loan and because the result
of these negotiations will be crucial I
take it for granted that we should focus
on these disagreements that I mentioned
before and that we should focus on the
possibility of political and social
alliances in Europe that will help us
achieve the best result the ECB will be
headed down to Athens probably as soon
as this week as part of the troika to
start monitoring the implementation of
those reforms and you've got to hope
things do go smoothly because that will
allow the ECB to continue to ease up on
the banks another 900 million euros
granted yesterday in a telephone
conference call for emergency liquidity
but the aim has got to be to get the
banks off emergency liquidity and back
onto standard ECB refinancing lines
which are cheaper but the ECB needs to
be sure it's going to get his money back
we're seeing xuhui numbers were seeing
export numbers come out with it so trade
balances have been affected you know the
consumer on retail spending is backing
away from doing things domestically so
the economy in Switzerland is still
suffering from the strongest Swiss franc
so we think that with Greece sideline
for now the Swiss franc should continue
to weaken especially against the US
dollar I think it's one of the probably
the clearest trades in the FX market
right now